geometric quantization seeks to
construct a quantum theory from a given
simplec manifold but how does this
process preserve the structure of
classical observables in the quantum
realm consider the cousant Sero
prequantization which requires a line
bundle over a simplec manifold the
bundle must satisfy the prequantization
condition in Duram kology why this
specific condition to answer observe
that for any classical observable
prequantization assigns a Quantum
operator like so but how does this
relate to Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle consider the commutator of two
such operators F hat and G hat well what
we do is we let the lead bracket equal
something proportional to the pan
bracket now what sucks is that this
prequantization alone isn't sufficient
it leads to way too large of a Hilbert
space so what's the remedy we polarize
we take a choice of a maximal integrable
lonian distribution on the manifold for
more on geometric quantization and
string theory visit this podcast with Ed
Frankle subscribe to get notified